what were you like when i was 25 when i
was 25 or so i probably weighed about
138 pounds i smoked like pack cigarettes
day i drank tremendous amount of alcohol
i was from northern alberta this rough
little town up in northern alberta
called fairview and you know there were
long winters there and my friends were
heavy drinkers and most of them dropped
out of school by the time they were 15
or 16 went off to work on the oil rigs
and you know it was a rough town and we
drank a lot i started when i was 14 and
i had a lot of bad habits let's say and
i wasn't in great shape physically and i
was also still intellectually obsessed
by as i am now but i decided around that
about 85 84 something like that maybe a
little earlier that i was really going
to try to get my act together and
so i started doing that i you know i
first of all i quit smoking oh that took
a long time because i eventually had to
quit drinking too in order to quit
smoking and i started working out
starting playing sports which i'd never
done i was a small kid i'd been skipped
a grade and i was a small small for my
age so sports were never especially team
sports were never really a domain of
expertise for me
although i skied and went trapping with
my dad went you know cross-country
skiing and camping and all that so but
uh when i went to graduate school i
started swimming
the first uh physical exercise routine i
did i enrolled in a
swimsuit course i think it was called so
it was me and this like really
overweight kid and like these 60 year
old women and men they could out
exercise me like mad it was really
embarrassing me and the overweight kid
you know we'd be just panting ourselves
three quarters to death at the end of
the bloody workout and these 60 year old
women who weren't in great shape or like
you know chatting away
as if nothing was going on at all in the
pool so that was quite embarrassing and
when i started working out when i was a
kid i was weighed about 130 pounds and i
was six foot one was a thin kid and i
smoked a lot i wasn't in good shape and
i went to the gym and it was bloody
embarrassing you know people would come
over and help me with the goddamn
weights here's how you're supposed to
use this you know it was humiliating and
maybe i was pressing 65 pounds or
something at that point you know but
what am i going to do i'm going to lift
up 150 pounds and injure myself right
off the bat no i had to go in there and
strip down and put my skinny goddamn
self in front of the mirror and think
son of a [ __ ] there's all these
monsters in the gym who've been lifting
weights for 10 years and i'm struggling
to get 50 pounds off the bar tough luck
for me but i could lift 50 pounds and it
wasn't very very long until i could lift
75 and well you know how it goes and i
never injured myself when i was
weightlifting and the reason for that
was i never pushed myself past where i
knew i could go and i pushed myself a
lot you know i gained 35 pounds of
muscle in about three years in in
university i kind of had to quit because
i was eating so goddamn much i couldn't
stand it it's eating like six meals a
day it was just taking up too much time
but there's a humility in determining
what it is that the wretched creature
that you are can actually manage aim low
and i don't mean don't aim and i don't
mean don't aim up you can set yourself a
goal that you can attain and there's not
going to be much glory in it to begin
with because if you're not in very good
shape the goal that you could attain
tomorrow isn't very glorious but it it's
a hell of a lot better than nothing and
it beats the hell out of bitterness and
it's way better than blaming someone
else it's way less dangerous and you
could do it there's a statement in the
new testament it's called the matthew
principle and economists use it to
describe how the economy and the world
works to those who have everything more
will be given from those who have
nothing everything will be taken it's
like what's very pessimistic in some
sense because it means that as you start
to fail you fail more and more rapidly
but it also means that as you start to
succeed you succeed more and more
rapidly and so you take an incremental
step and well now you can lift 55 pounds
instead of 52.5 pounds you think well
what the hell's that it's like it's one
step on a very long journey and it
starts to compound on you so a small
step today means puts you in a position
to take a slightly bigger step the next
day and then that puts you in a position
to take a slightly bigger step the next
day and you do that for two or three
years man you're starting to stride so
like i was kind of a wild man and you
know i'm a little bit manic in my in my
uh temperament and so you know i was i
was kind of going every direction at the
same time you know i don't regret that i
had a fine time when i was a kid and but
i needed really to get disciplined and i
had to do it because i was working on
these hard problems that you know that
i've been discussing with all of you and
i've been working on them really you
know obsessively since
i was probably about 18 maybe even
earlier than that got to the point
around 25 when i was in graduate school
trying to get my phds doing all my
research like i published 15 papers by
the time i graduated with my phd which
was by a fairly large measure the most
papers that any un graduate student at
that time had ever published at mcgill
and at the same time i wrote maps of
meaning which was a terrible terrible
terribly difficult thing to do because i
was writing about three hours a day
doing that and i couldn't do all that
and continue with my misbehavior you
know my sort of my what what would you
say my massive hedonistic consumption of
alcohol and all of that i just couldn't
keep it up and also work seriously on
the issues that were at hand so you know
i had to stop that's a sacrifice i had
to stop i noticed when i was
in my early twenties that
the only time i really
regretted what i had done
was when i was drinking
now it was also interfering with me
writing because i couldn't concentrate
well enough if i was hungover i couldn't
tolerate the emotional strain of what i
was writing about when i was hungover it
was too i couldn't handle being on the
edge because i destabilized my nervous
system
in any case i stopped drinking and the
reason for that was well i decided i
didn't want to be ashamed of what i was
doing anymore i thought well maybe i
could not do things that were shameful
and then see what my life was like so
that that was sort of on the negative
end the constraint end i think people
get on the more positive end people get
deeply involved in what they're doing if
they're in the right place in the right
time so that you i would say you can
tell this is the idea of heaven on earth
to some degree when time stops when
you're not aware of the duration of time
when you're so engaged with what you're
doing that you're not aware of the
duration of time
then then you've got the forces of chaos
balance and order balanced properly it's
you're not stultified and bored that's
an excess of order
everything's too predictable you're not
overwhelmed you're you're dealing with
it's like it's like it's you're playing
tennis at the peak of your game that's
partly what people experience when
they're great athletes when they play
the zone yeah no and they're always
stretching themselves to their limit you
can tell that if you watch a gymnast for
example who has a brilliant performance
they've stretched themselves beyond
their domain of competence during the
performance and that's what makes
everybody leap to their feet that's the
incarnation given
embodiment right there in front of you
for some moments and everyone cheers
that on it requires even to some degree
some good fortune to maintain i
certainly haven't been able to do that
well i was ill one of the consequences
of of my illness whatever it was or is
was time dilation like days lasted weeks
it seemed like minutes lasted hours and
i mean that literally
was terrible the weight of time it's the
weight of brute mortality it's the
weight of self-consciousness
and you escape that immersed properly if
you're not
who you want to be then think about how
you could be better take a chance aim at
that work at it and see what happens i
got married while my the woman who's my
wife tammy who i've known since she was
eight years old she lived across the
street from me in this little town
called fairview and i was in love with
her like the first time i saw her which
is quite bloody thing so that's worked
out pretty well for me but she came to
live with me
about the same time and you know we
decided jointly to get our act together
and we swore that we tell each other the
truth which i think she's actually done
better than me like i don't think i
don't think she's lied to me ever in our
entire marriage which is unbelievable
you know and it's been so useful because
i can really tell her things that we can
really talk so i tell you if you want to
have a good relationship man you embed
it in the truth because if you don't
embed it in the truth you don't have a
relationship it's just lies it's a
tissue of lies and it will it will
dissolve in the chaos as soon as the
crisis comes along so the truth is a
terrible thing but not not compared to
falsehood
[Music]